one of the greatest advantages of the
cloud is how easy it can be to scale
your usage up or down however if you're
working with a predictable compute
workload you can save some money with
committed use discounts on this episode
of beyond your bill we'll talk about
what committed use discounts are and how
you can maximize your usage of them
[Music]
comitted use discounts or Cu DS for
short are basically contracts saying
you'll commit to a certain amount of
compute engine resource for a 1 or 3
year period in exchange for your
commitment you'll get a significant
price discount even as high as 70% in
some cases you can make these
commitments on typical compute resources
such as V CPUs and memory but also on
GPUs and local SSDs it's worth noting
that committed use discounts aren't the
same thing as sustained use discounts
which are separate discounts that can't
be combined with committed use discounts
there's a link below with more
information on those let's look a bit
more at how to set up commitments and
then explore the committed use discount
analysis report which allows you to
visualize your commitments this report
is meant to help you answer questions
like how much of my eligible compute
engine usage is covered by my
commitments
how much are my commitments actually
saving me and am I fully utilizing my
existing commitments to start you can
purchase commitments in the Google Cloud
console by using the top left navigation
and clicking on committed used discounts
under compute engine from here click on
purchase commitment to enter the
specifics such as the time frame and
which resource you want to purchase each
commitment is purchased for a specific
project and region commitments for V
CPUs and memories are applied
simultaneously but you can have separate
commitments for GPUs and local SSDs
you'll also get an estimated cost to let
you see how much you'll pay each month
and how much the commitment would save
you if you run into the issues
purchasing a commitment you may need to
make sure that you have a quota for it
there's also a link below with more
information for that once you've made
the commitment you'll start to pay for
that commitment over its lifetime with
each billing cycle even if you don't
have any resources active in this
example a certain amount of V CPUs and
RAM have been used by a compute engine
instance the amount that's covered by a
commitment will be credited back and the
lower commitment rate will be applied
for that usage however if you've got
lots of resources and commitments it can
be confusing to see exactly what you're
spending and which commitments you have
active especially since commitments
don't auto renew that's where the
committed use discount analysis report
comes in it helps you visualize all of
your commitments alongside your computer
resources using the Google cloud console
choose a billing account and click
Commitments option to get to the report
you'll need to be a billing account
administrator or building account viewer
to see this report
unlike billing reports you won't be able
to get access to this report just by
being a project owner though you will be
able to filter by project let's step
through the different areas to see how
the report works the resources are split
up by type so you can see v cpu ram SSD
and each type of GPU separately with
your usage and the relevant commitments
you can toggle between them by clicking
the tabs here but we'll start with V
CPUs above the graph you can see a quick
summary of your commitments the left
side lets you see if you're looking at
all regions or if you're only looking at
a specific region which I'll show you
how to do in just a second the middle
shows the current number of active
commitments which may take a day or two
to update when a new commitment is
purchased the right side shows you the
utilization of your commitments by
comparing the amount of eligible usage
being covered by your commitments to the
total number of commitments that you
have you can also hover over the
question mark for the specific resource
counts the stacked bar chart itself
shows you the resource users for each
day the amount that was covered by a
commitment and a line that shows you the
current quantity of commitments you can
hover over each column to see the exact
usage numbers for every day there's also
a summary table below the chart let's
take a look at a specific subset of days
here you can see the usage narrowed down
to a few days on the first day all
commitments were fully utilized and
there were additional eligible resource
usage on top of your purchase
commitments if you often see resource
uses above your additional commitments
it may make sense to purchase additional
commitments to cover that usage and save
some money however you could also see
that on the next few days the
commitments haven't changed but the
amount used has since this is the cloud
it makes sense that resource users can
fluctuate but how can we find out why
these resources weren't covered let's
drill down using the filters you can
also change the time ranges here if you
want to see more dates well change the
view to region and see the specific
split up by each region this is the US
central one region but the graph is
still showing the same usage pattern
remember that committed use discounts
are specific to a project and a region
so let's use the filters to select a
specific project
with this filter we can see that less V
CPUs were used for a few days in this
project which led to the commitment
being underutilized understanding more
details about commitment utilization can
give you a much better idea of how to
plan for future usage of resources or
even where you may want to purchase
additional commitments as you've seen
committed dues discounts can save you
money on your compute engine resources
especially if you have a lot of
consistent usage it's also important to
use the committed use discount analysis
report to see how your existing
commitments are sizing up and if it
makes sense to purchase additional
commitments check out the links for more
information and try out the report for
yourself in the GCB console
[Music]